معنى من دبي المتحدث الاقليمي باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه سامويل وبرج اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد صامويل ما الذي يحمله الوزير
بلانكن للجانب الاسرائيلي
اذا مساء الخير
والرساله للاسرائيليين لم تتغير بالنسبه
الموقف الامريكي لان لدينا موقف ملكي بنيت
على السياسه وليس على الاشخاص وبالرقم من
سيدير الحكومه الاسرائيليه لدينا عن نفس
السياسه والولايات المتحده ترعى انها
لدينا علاقات ثنائيات تاريخيه قويه جدا مع
اسرائيل وان نحن ندعم حق ياسر على الدفاع
عن النفس وفي نفس الوقت نحن كل الاطراف في
حدث وقت صعب يخفض التساهيل ونحن همم
الولايات المتحده دودي اي شيء
خاصه في هذا الوقت
طيب ماذا عن الاجراءات الاحاديه التي
اتخذت بالفعل من جانب الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وتتخذ طوانا الوقت ما الذي ستقولون
الاسرائيليين
بدون ان ادخل في تفاصيل بالنسبه هذه
المناقشه شاعر لنا الان وزير برينغن هو
سيوصل الى اسرائيل وهو الذي بعد
الاجتماعات اليوم وايضا هو لديه بعد
الاجتماعات بكره مع القدر الفلسطينيين
منهم رئيس محمود عباس اذن انا لا اريد
بيانات او اي تفاصيل من هذه الاجتماعات
ولكن بدون شكل نحن سنشدد او الوزير هو
سيسدد في هذه اللقاءات اهميه في هذا الوقت
انخفضت اسرائيل وحفاظ على امكانيه للعوده
الى المفاوضات للوصول الى حل الدولتين وكل
الاجراءات الحديثه جانبنا من اي امكانيه
للوصول الى هذه الدولتين
في رايكم الفلسطينيون يتخذون اي اجراءات
احاديه الجانب
اذا راينا انا لا اريد ان ان اجمع كل
الفلسطينيين لان راينا بكل اسف وراينا
هجومه ارهابيه مؤخرا وانا لا اريد ان اقول
ان هذا من الجانب الفرسنه لان نحن نعرف ان
هذا من الافراد من بعد المجموعات
الارهابيه وانا لا اريد السلطه الفلسطينيه
في نفس المكان وفي نفس الجمله اذا لازم
نفرق ولا لازم ناكل الان العلاقات المتحده
والفلسطينيين نحن في هذه الاداره قمنا
باستئنا في العلاقات وبكل اسف الاداره
السابقه الامريكيه قطعت العلاقات مع
الفرنسيين وقطعت المساعده الانسانيه
والاقتصاديه الى الفلسطيني اذا اول شيء
اذا الولد المتاهله تريد ان تلعب اي دوري
ايجابي بين الجانبين لازم تكون لديها
علاقه علاقه ما جانبيه وهذه سنتين كان
الوقت استئناف العلاقات مع الفلسطينيين
وقمنا بدالات وقمنا باستئنا الساده
الانسانيه واقتصادي وامنيه للفارسين
والولايات المتحده قدم الاكثر من 890
مليون دولار في مساعده انسانيه واقتصاديه
للفلسطينيين الولايات المتحده امتنعت عن
التصويت في عهد الرئيس باراك اوباما على
القرار
02334 الذي ادانا الاستيطان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واعتبره غير قانونيه الان
هنالك خطط لهذه الحكومه لبناء الكثير
والمزيد من المستوطنات وتوسيع صلاحيات حتى
المستوطنين وتسليح المستوطنين همم هل
تعتقدون ان هذه الاجراءات تساعد على الاقل
الرؤيه الامريكيه في حال الدولتين وفي خفض
التصعيد هذا بجانب الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
المستمره اليوميه
والاشتياحات للضفه الغربيه هل تعتقدون ان
ذلك يساعد في التهدئه
لا لا الموقف الملكي واضحه ورئيس بايدن
ووزير بريكن وكل مسؤولين الامريكيين كان
واجهين جدا حول هذه النقطه الولايات
المتحده ضد توصيه المستوطنات نحن ضد
الفلسطينيين نحن ضد ذلك نحن نتكلم
بصوت عالي الموقف امام الوسائل في هذه
الاجتماعات في اسرائيل مع المسلمين
هل الولايات المتحده لديها الان اي مبادره
لاطلاق عمليه السلام
اذا نحن ندرك انا من ساعه وبنتكلمه حول
عمليه سلام بين جانبين عندما لا نرى موقف
مواهب في الجانبين لا لانرا موقف معاهد
بين الفلسطينيين
والان امامنا حكومه جديده في اسرائيل وحتى
الان ليس وعددها موقفها بنسبه اي عمليه
الوقت الان وهذا السبب الرئيسي لماذا
وكل هؤلاء المصلين الاخرين ذكرت في
تقريركم لماذا هم زاروا المنطقه اللي انا
لازم نسمع الولايات المتحده لا تريد
اراداتها لا تريد رؤيهنا على الجانبيه لا
لازم نسمع من الاسرائيليين ولازم الاسماء
من الفلسطينيين يعني دلوقت المتاحده تسمع
من الطرفين منذ 80 عاما والقضيه لا تحل
يعني في كل المرات التي اطلقت فيها عمليه
السلام لم يكن بمبادره فلسطينيه اسرائيليه
ولكن بر من قوه كبرى فلماذا تتاخر
الولايات المتحده عن القيام بهذا الدور في
ظل هذه الاداره
ههه اذا همم كما ذكرنا همم هذه السنتين
كان وقت الاستئناف العلاقات مع
الفلسطينيين ليس من الممكن ان نتوقعن
الفلسطينيين اا سيكونوا لديهم ثقه في
الولايات المتحده بدون اي علاقه والان
لدينا الشخص الذي امر هو في المنزل واول
مره في تاريخ الذين
اي اداره امريكيه المبعوث الخاص للشؤون
الفلسطينيه
وهذا همم الرساله واضحه الفلسطينيين نريد
ان نسمع منهم نريد نكون لدينا علاقه
مباشره مع الفلسطينيين ونحن الان من هذه
زياره وكل الزيارات الاخرى نحن نسمع من
الفلسطينيين وهمم همم كل الادارات منذ
اكثر من 40 و50 سنه والاكثر همم كانت تحول
ان ان تحث الاطراف
ولكن بالرقم من همم همم عدم النجاح حتى
الان ليس من الممكن او ليس
لنبذل كل ما في وسائلنا
للشيعه لتشجيع هذه الاطراف لجلوس ولا
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من دبي المتحدث
الاقليميه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
الصامويل